Lady gentleman,
black helicopters have been spotted your podcasts with your wife's one of my
favorite podcasts.
It's so fucking consistently silly thing.
It is very so ridiculous and people get silly when they get on it and they do.
And then you know,
I start like seeing things like,
oh this is like a your mom's house bit.
I need to send it to Tom.
Yeah,
you sent me a couple of good ones.
I can't tell a story about taking this shit without 90 people hitting me up the
next day telling me that was the most brilliant story in the world we want to
send at the ago.
And I tell him,
I tell her shit,
no shit comic.
It's awesome.
Myself.
I'm two days later.
It sure it up.
I'm wearing the fucking youtube video.
That's true.
Play Joey telling shit stories for sure.
And he told us about money shit,
uh,
in his backyard and somebody thought it was a barren.
She would leave,
she would let her dogs out every day and then she would clean up.
They will French poodles.
Yeah.
Which is really back from the shit.
This shit.
Joe Rogan,
she looked at it and she was like 58 so she's squinting at this up against the
wall.
But here's what I took a shit and I put my back against the wall.
So when I shift,
when you shit outside,
it's not going to be a decent shit.
It's going to be like explosive.
So when I got up and it looks like somebody got shot in the head that we should
all behind me.
So she's sitting there with a little French poodles,
I little Chihuahuas and she's looking at the wall like,
what the fuck happened?
Then all of a sudden she actually walks up close to it and squints and looks and
looks around and runs in the house.
I'm watching all this,
I can't breathe.
And now I go to the computer cause my wife's very decent sitting there forever.
And then my wife comes in,
she goes,
where are you home all day today?
I go,
yeah,
why?
She goes,
I just had a conversation with Susan.
She wanted to know if you heard anything in the backyard,
cause some animals to be shit back then I went,
I want to get Sushi but give it a go get Sushi.
I eat a lot of it.
The rice pushes everything I asked and you had a plan is to go give it a weed
store.
You want to go to post office.
But I made a detour.
I plan to go home,
but I left the house key in the house so I had to climb around the window.
That's what happened.
Yeah.
So when I pulled myself up,
I actually landed with my stomach on the window and that you're really,
which made it push it out more and I'm saddened and fuck and my hands are
struggling in the window or on the other side.
And the cat said meow and I'd be scratching at me,
right.
And I'm like,
it's me your fuck.
So I ran out,
ran down the stairs.
I was shit outside.
Oh my God,
this was the amount.
I took a shit in favor in his backyard after a five hour drive from Colton or
some weird town.
Did he not talk to you after that?
For Awhile I took a shit and then he ran over it with his car and the whole back
yard smells like sewage.
I'd go with her the next day he goes,
it smells back here.
Let's talk in the house.
I don't know what happened and you can see that Brown shit.
You smushed it with this tire and a bunch of fly to
talk to me for a month after that in some of these backyard
because I told him the truth.
I felt bad for the guy.
That's hard to clean up too.
Yeah.
Shit.
You can see up dog shit.
It doesn't even make you gag like human shit bomb shit to clean up some wine.
Oh Shit.
If yet.
He's one of those scrapers.
It smells so much stronger man.
It's so much.
No,
no,
no.
When you take a shit til you cut it in half,
cut the shit when that,
when that Reese's peanut butter perfume leaks out.
Oh my God.
I've done studies.
When you're going to jail,
when you go to prison,
you have to cut the shit.
The shit like in the two.
But people watching TV,
like when you go to county jail,
you shit right there.
So black guys,
we'll be laying there watching TV with their feet up and also that small little
shit in there like put some water in that whole motherfucker.
Like they'll just yell it cause the other side of the fucking prison.
What's it?
Cause that means you,
you took a shit and just sitting there.
So in prison,
as soon as your shit,
you got to put water on it.
Yeah.
But then some bathrooms that only give you 20 ounces of water a day.
So whatever time you flush,
it's gotta be a good flush.
You're following me.
So you pick a pitch.
Sometimes a piss has to stay there until the next day until you take a good good
shit.
But when you take a shit in jail,
bro,
that's what they'll tell you.
Cause some water.
But some hole in that motherfucking old dog,
I could smell that shit.
Right now I'm trying to watch Oprah,
but that's what smells one stuff sucks.
It's like when you go to Vegas to have that sucking action will,
if you take a shit this big that's 34 inches,
once that thing it breaks and it looks like two new chucks.
Once that breaks,
it's over,
it's over.
And they put the bathroom right by the door,
the front entrance.
You can't have nobody come over.
Right.
That's why I always go downstairs to take shit.
I don't Shit my bathroom in the hotel no more cause it kills the whole room for
two hours.
We worked at the House of Blues and Vegas and uh,
Joey left,
uh,
an onshore shit.
You know what an onshore shit is.
He,
he was so fat at the time that he couldn't sit down and like the regular toilet.
You were like,
what were you wanting to do this for?
15,
he was dying.
He was giant.
So when he would take his shit,
he would had have to balance himself mostly on the very edge of the front
because his ass was so big.
Why and Shit in the water out on the deck.
No.
Oh,
you ain't never seen shit like that before.
So you couldn't sit in the toilet.
I would fill in the toilet,
but I don't like,
my logo was on the edge.
It wasn't that I was fat.
I don't like my dick inside the toilet.
Right.
He's gonna suck his Dick and Austin.
They're stuck in the toilet.
I tell my wife,
I don't even let my wife pee in public because I want to eat her monkey.
I don't want that monkey touching me.
So when I shit in a public bathroom,
I hope my balls and I shit towards the edge.
I don't give a fuck at somebody else's backroom.
Just hold your balls and sit where you are because none of them you to move
forward.
Because if I'm back there,
I got crabs one time I left that sitting on the toilet.
They'll jump from that toilet inward like they jumping over a month.
People saying they got crabs to the toilet as an excuse.
Sometimes you could Greg crabs from anywhere.
But why you think you to get it from him?
They only cleaned the hairs.
I don't think they like little stay on an actual toilet.
Probably.
Definitely.
Right.
Yeah.
I wouldn't feel like that's one of the things like black crabs.
I took a shirt at the gas station that had to be at,
that's what Ivan's figured.
It was not,
I'm sorry.
I always hold my nuts.
Shit when I shit it was long and red band put ketchup on it.
Remember red band put ketchup on it.
Unfortunately,
I think that was a different time.
Okay.
This is not happening just for us.
It's been many,
many times things just like sticking out.
So you go in there,
there's a smell.
You know how when you take an epic shit,
it's an above watershed.
It comes out like,
like the fucking big island of Hawaii just rises through the water.
Like I've done that many times where because I eat too much and I'll take these
shits that are just like so big.
They're preposterous,
but there's a totally different smell to those shifts cause you're smelling raw
shit outside of the water.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's gone through the water and it's poking into the strong.
What is it about that that makes you happy?
What is it about the sense of accomplishment?
First of all.
Good one right here.
It doesn't come around that often either.
No.
Yeah,
man.
It's like a comment like I don't eat.
This doesn't happen all the time.
It's always diarrhea too.
It's never like,
it's never like a super,
it's like thick law.
It's weird when the second wave is diarrhea,
like when you take long and you're proud of yourself and then you're like,
I think I got a little more in there and it's like,
ah.
It's just the fucking,
you know what that's from what?
Healthy eating.
Healthy eating does that.
Yeah.
If you eat some MCT oil or coconut oils and lubes up your pipes,
because where I moved to now I have the office,
the back office,
and it's connected to a bathroom.
It's got a door,
so I don't live with this stick no more.
I opened the door in the morning.
I was living with a stick in the back yard.
I Shit,
I smoked a bowl of shit backyard anymore.
No,
no,
no.
My dog goes faces to the back yard dog.
I had my own bathroom and the bedroom.
Then one of them.
That's what I want to put a woman.
No,
I got back there.
Yeah.
Leave her alone.
Open the back door.
Fuck the fuck fan.
I just open the back door.
There's the school behind that kid's playing.
I'm shitting smoking dope.
I don't give a freshman as fuck and I don't smell it.
Then I'm like,
why the candle?
That's beautiful.
Beautiful.
That's what you need is a bathroom with a door that faces outside.
The worst is when you go over a girl's house and he'd go to use your bathroom
and you smell matches.
Oh yeah.
Oh No,
she was lightless motherfucker up.
Yeah.
It's all you're thinking about burning off fumes.
The Stinky Butt.
I hate packing about her math.
You ever get to a girl's place and then you feel the gurgles and you're like,
that's not good.
I've had that before.
I was dating a girl once and she had a ferocious diarrhea.
Ferocious.
So she was in one time and she,
so she went to the bathroom and she just turned on the shower and she turns on
both things on the sink.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And just she tried to drown it out,
call it.
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
I was very young at the time.
We didn't understand what,
I was super confused.
What the fuck is going on in there.
I had,
I had once in,
in college where I was at this girl's place and she was just like,
okay,
it's game on.
Like go for it.
Right?
It's like I have to take,
I could feel that it was a diarrhea,
nothing explosive diarrhea,
Shit.
And I also realized there was no way to do it that,
that it would just be a black toilet and that there's no way I could cover.
She know what I did.
I went back to my place.
I was like,
I'll,
uh,
I'll see you some other time or whatever.
And the next day her friends were like,
you're like the fucking,
like they gave me credit that they think that I was a good cause they were like,
you're awesome.
And I was like,
no,
I have to take,
because they're not getting fucked and they don't want their friend to get
fucked.
Right.
So they use reverse psychology on you.
You're an amazing guy.
I got an amazing guy.
Credit.
Hope you wait forever.
A circle that you left.
Even when you get married.
Tell her we get married
and have sex after you're married.
Never.
That's not about that,
right?
It's about real live.
Well,
if I had had bowels that were intact,
it would have been a different story that night.
But the house bowels,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
There's a time when you know that it's and the sensitivity of your inner asshole
region.
It is.
It knows,
especially when you go to seep out of Fart,
right?
When you're like,
you're like about to cut a fart and then also the alarms start going off.
You're like,
oh no.
Oh Yeah,
And you've got a clamp shot.
Like,
Ooh,
Jesus.
What is this?
We were having this debate yesterday about why are they sometimes hot,
like why is it hot and then why does,
why do you know that hot going to smell bad spicy food bro?
Is it,
but is that what it is solely?
I don't know.
I was telling you guys at one time my freshman year,
I didn't pick a shift for a week and a half.
I was with Dick at this fake comes with American cheese and all right or fries.
How long is that?
This is a long time.
I was in,
I played freshman ball and we were playing Paddison east side.
It's just a jungle of a school.
Like you gotta be careful when you go in there
and uh,
we went there to play the Christmas tournament.
Well,
what kind of ball are we talking about?
Basketball.
I hadn't taken this shift from like 10 days or something.
I took acid,
something fuck my stomach about it until nobody in those days I was really
scared of doctors and I wouldn't say shit to nobody.
No Way.
Home we got on the bus
and while we were waiting there,
my stomach started hurting and I said,
Jesus Christ,
I don't know if I'm going to shoot myself a Fart,
but let me just take a chance.
And I blew this far.
Joe Rogan,
that was so bad.
We want a bus.
And people started running,
you know,
the school buses.
People started running to the windows,
right.
To swing down the bus windows.
But here's where it gets better.
I farther again,
I,
the teachers would go,
oh my God,
he's changing flavors.
Yeah.
What's the worst thing was the cheerleaders are crying.
That's how bad bus
or
the teachers yell.
Dot.
God He's changing.
That's how bad these parts will.
The whole bus forget looking at the cheerleaders.
And they were like,
Oh my God,
we've never smelled like this.
But if I was fucking God awful,
I wrote a blog about one to Joyce fart.
Is that on a plane?
They got rid of that.
It's called happy pills.
And it was,
I was thinking about,
I was,
I was looking at this ad,
take this,
I was looking at this ad for antidepressant.
My God,
you know,
some girl dancing around a field of wheat and shit.
You know those stills ads.
Yeah.
And uh,
I was just thinking about like,
like what,
you know,
what depresses people and how crazy pills are and how Craig,
oh,
it's still up there.
You can still find it anyway.
Anyway,
at the end of this,
this is a really like me.
We're both,
both of us are barbecued.
I don't know what the fuck.
What do we add?
A bowl?
Some sort of edibles in the beginning lollipops way they'd be giving.
The boys were crucified.
Rogan was asleep.
Yeah,
he was going in and out,
but he wrote on the blog,
and I don't even have to look at the farm was strong.
He's lucky.
I farted it because it was a lot better than the Antonio Banderas movie.
He was watching something to do's on Antonio Banderas moving in.
I don't remember what it was,
what it was,
but I do remember the lady behind you.
I will never forget hearing her over the earphones.
Yeah,
I hear.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Over the pounding sound in my iPod.
I hear a woman in the row behind us cry out.
Oh my God.
[inaudible] Joey and he smiles.
There's your fucking happy pill right there.
That's your right Antonio.
Banderas it says,
oh,
what was it?
Oh yeah,
teaching underprivileged youth.
How to salsa.
Oh,
that's what I was watching.
I was watching a terrible movie.
Terrible.
We both were,
and Joey farted,
the fart evolve man.
Do you remember by the way,
you walk the seat back to those parts,
will you actually feel your leg?
It's like you're in when you were in a plane and it's going to go down.
What's the button you push the throat and it was just to a little bit.
He blames his seat belt into your waist.
My God,
it was terrible.
But another time I fought,
I used to,
I used to take the number one bus from Jersey City at all Bergen for the high
school and we were on the bus one morning kids and there was a guy reading a
paper.
I could live to be a hundred and never forget this reading the Daily News.
And he had a connector of drool from his Lyft to the daily news and there was a
puddle.
He was on heroin.
They would go to Jersey City in those days and get methadone.
So they would take the bus up north with her.
So I'm sitting there,
he's passed the fuck out and the drool is connected to the daily news and
there's got to be just six inches of power.
This guy's been passed out for 20 minutes.
I point my aunt's at them,
I'm not sitting behind them,
I'm sitting across from them and I lift up.
My hips are a little bit just like kept my ass hoe.
Just pointing out that even if it wasn't pointed at them,
it would ricochet off the chair and go straight and through his mouth.
Like he's sitting there and I let her fuck go out.
I could live to be 80 he lifted his eyes like this person,
like he went like this first like hey once his mouth and he's like,
man,
who the fuck?
He goes,
it's about
died and me and my little buddies were like,
what the fuck and giggling and he's like,
I should beat the fuck out of whatever the father,
I'm just,
oh my God,
fantastic.
Jesus.
Oh man,
this is what,
this is why I hate people.
This is why I hate when I read post to give me a second.
This is the reason why I read posts from people going,
are you sick of nine was blue comedy will come down to the standard fee in
Friday night and listened to intelligent comedy comp,
fuck,
fuck provoking comedy.
And then I think about it,
how many times I'm 54 years old and at night I got a sleep apnea machine and
there's a little needle in the sleep apnea machine because the hall was punches
air into your fucking mouth.
So there's an escape valve that's the size of a needle.
You know how many nights I will sit there and be half asleep and I'll meet the,
and I'll wake up just the farm to see if I could smell the fucking fart.
Come through that whole yes,
if it comes through,
it's a tremendous fight.
I just wake up,
my wife like I go on it.
You got it.
Held it like it's that good.
I'm 54 years old.
That always makes me laugh.
Pumps to Gore.
Yeah.